you might remember Donald Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen for this classic legal
argument but you guys are down and it
makes us that they would so most of them
all of them
what is maybe some of Hugh Laurie's best
characters oh yeah you know the last
season a house got real weird it's nice
to know that if he or Trump ever get in
trouble their defense is gonna be a
bitch says what confidence I want to use
that the next time someone tries to
break up with me I'll just be like says
who now Cohen Sweeting out divine proof
that Donald is gonna win this cloud
and he wrote in case anyone is unsure as
to who will be our next POTUS the Lord
has chosen the people's messenger and
those little tiny cloud hands at the
bottom or just give it a comedians look
the weather report for this picture
yes J we have a dumb front moving in
from the east
Clinic I think it's more complicated
than that that is a very difficult
weather system to predict it is a severe
tornado warning but only for Latinos I
think those wisps of clouds were taken
from another cloud that I do as their
Cloudy with a Chance of a guy who looks
like meatballs yes